here for the show I'm definitely here
for the show
between hitmonkey Harley Quinn and now
Twisted Metal I understand that trailers
for comedy shows tend to make them look
horrifically unwatchable no matter how
good they may be when you see the final
product I've come to report that despite
the marketing doing a major disservice
peacock's Twisted Metal TV series is
actually pretty good I've been a fan of
the game since uh 2001 I guess and I can
confidently say that the show pulled off
a really entertaining tribute to the
characters and history of the series and
left me wanting to see more join me in
pan pizza driver of the Rebel taxi in
one of my YouTube Idols as we run down
what made this show such a fun ride and
how much we wanted to keep on trucking
further down the road
car pun now word from our sponsor
special thanks to Manta sleep for
sponsoring this video Manta sleep is
dedicated to creating Better Lives
through better sleep and their pronap
movement through their affordable and
well-crafted sleeping desks the pro nap
movement is about rejecting
counterproductive nap shame and
corporate BS and reclaiming which should
have always been yours in the first
place Your vitality because the truth is
your body is wired to nap and for good
reason naps give you energy Focus
strength and Clarity that you don't get
when you grind through the afternoon
they give you what we call a second
morning mantis leaves masks come in a
variety of different styles for
different sleeping needs for example my
wife has a hard time sleeping at night
because I like to leave the TV on watch
cartoons until 3am so the Manta steam
mask helps her to relax and hydrates
drier itchy eyes with relief in just
three to five minutes
soft durable and snag free materials
make it a worthy inclusion in your sleep
cycle
the Manta sleeps website and use my
discount code for 10 off your first
purchase now back to the video
one of PlayStation's most recognizable
franchises that they gave up on Twisted
Metal as a fighting game on Wheels car
combat with missiles Napalm and human
projectiles that explode depending on
which of your chosen drivers wins the
Twisted Metal tournament you'll watch
them earn a single Wish by the contest
holder Calypso so these wishes act as a
monkey's Paul as nothing ever goes right
these games were brutal funny horrific
and on the rare occasions emotional this
TV series manages to mix all that
together for years I've heard rumors of
a TM movie or show only to finally be
fulfilled as a longtime fan in high
school I bought Twisted Metal head-on
just because it was 20 bucks new well
that just opened the floodgates for me
really when coming up with rubble taxi
some spitballed name ideas were TM
references Harbor City and yellow jacket
which was the taxi vehicle how I draw my
Loki IRL character is influenced by how
I used to draw Sweet Tooth in my school
planner I love the games and its
ever-changing continuity and many people
assume the dark reboot Twisted Metal
black is how all the games are but no
nearly each one was different what's the
origin of a certain character who drives
the car what race are they what's their
special move that all changes depending
on the game the first clip of the TV
series shown off angered fans with the
quote MCU humor
I'm guessing you don't fight much
outside of your car now do you even the
director of the games David Jaffe was
discussed by the Comic-Con footage of
Sweet Tooth the clown twerking what in
the goddamn uh [__] Sam Hill I was a
bit wary too but I accepted the earlier
games didn't take themselves seriously
either plus Michael Jonathan Smith was
on board a major writer for multiple
Cobra Kai seasons he mentioned wanting
to pull references from every game which
was perfect Cobra Kai is full of
character drama and fan service Twisted
Metal could do the same my dad rented
Twisted Metal black from Hollywood Video
around the time it came out and some of
my first memories are him in my Uncle
playing it all day and night during the
weekends trying to get every ending with
every character
when I was that age this game seemed so
adult and hardcore but looking back now
I see that it still had some silly
points in terms of the franchise it's
still the darkest because you get a
character who is the literal Grim Reaper
and was absorbing Souls into his
tackling skeleton body and then see him
turn into a disturbed cannibalistic
Vietnam veteran in an insane asylum
but like sweet tooth's ice cream truck
still turns into a Transformer I knew
when I got to the 2012 game that the
ideal tone for the series was a nice
Middle Ground between the silly and Grim
dark takes I think the peacock series
it's that sweet spot because it knows
when to get dark and cruel but it also
knows how to have fun I was never
completely uncomfortable and depressed
watching the show but I wasn't also
getting irritated by the overuse of
humor in inappropriate moments imagine
to tell that line so that I was vibing
with it and having fun throughout all 10
episodes the series follows a delivery
driver and a post-apocalyptic United
States that has to go on a cross-country
road trip to pull off a job that no one
else can
Sam Porter Bridges with the promise of
being able to move into one of the few
communities that hasn't been affected by
the catastrophe if he can bring back a
package successfully from the other side
of the nation along the way he keeps
bumping into wacky characters from the
franchise like agent Stone Sweet Tooth
Mike and Stu the preacher Amanda Watson
granny dread Six Bullets you put your
name on there dude get out of my car
right now
that's it I'm willing to negotiate John
Doe is our lead but he suffers from
Amnesia and desperately wants to know
where he came from but he also deflects
a lot of the craziness of the world he's
in with humor he never shuts up and even
the other characters acknowledge that
he's got a joke for everything hey
orl please
you just asked me for oral I think this
is the first show or movie I've seen him
in that's made me really love Anthony
Mackey I thought he was okay as Sam
Wilson but that character tends to take
himself more seriously barring the usual
MCU equips and it made me realize that
Mackie has some great comedy chops when
he has better jokes to tell he really
lets out his inner axle fully in this
show and he's so endearing and fun to
watch here I actually wish he got to
play more roles like this because he's
hilarious the other lead is an original
character created for the series who is
given the nickname quiet because she
doesn't speak much
she also absorbs moisture through given
that she had a brother named loud and
they had such an in-depth backstory and
a fun gimmick of one being serious and
the other being the loudmouth I
genuinely thought that they were both
characters from one of the games I
hadn't played maybe like a PSP spin-off
or something they just fit into this
world and bounce off these characters
well enough that I didn't give it a
second thought
so they're good additions to the
franchise unlike other OCS created for
video game adaptations that stick out
like a sore thumb after seeing so many
deep cut references to the game
characters and lore in all the locations
like blackfield Asylum or zorko Brothers
Scrap and Salvage I couldn't help but
think of that Halo series set on planet
reach where the game takes you to New
Alexandria and the show has
reach city you can really tell the
difference between a show made by people
who didn't really know or understand
anything about the games and a show made
by people who clearly loved the games
and Wanda cram and as many people on
locations from it as they were able to
there were references that had me saying
really you put that in I was impressed
the show was strangely not quite Twisted
Metal yet very Twisted Metal
Supernatural elements aren't here yet
they organically worked in wishes or
flaming heads and if you're gonna add
new characters to a show make them as
toyetic as possible quiet's outfit is
unique enough to fit that same for the
cult that covered themselves with
tinfoil if you told me there was a
driver called tin head from Twisted
Metal windshield wiper I wouldn't
believe it's not playing every game but
if I didn't I would believe it it's not
quite Twisted Metal but all I need was
car destruction and that's here the
games always center around a contest
between these crazy characters where
they battle each other in their souped
up death machines for the prize of a
wish being granted by the mysterious and
Powerful creator of the contest Calypso
every character in the game has
something thereafter and when you play
as them you unlock their ending where
they win the contest and get to make
their wish imagine a vehicle-based
equivalent to Mortal Kombat the fun
thing is that Calypso is a smart ass and
gives the winner some sort of ironic
twist to their wish so they end up
getting screwed over no matter what they
ask for we demand that you give us the
ability to fly certainly
that's so cool let's go
good to think these first class tickets
sure every character has a well-defined
backstory personality and desire that
makes for a strong cast in the games the
demon brought its foul influence upon me
and entered my mind all I could do was
cry out inside as I tore that church
killing everyone in the church are you
possessed I was once by a little demon
baby
[__] made me kill a whole church of
people which the show utilizes very well
every character who appears in the
series has pretty much the same
backstory and personality just modified
slightly to fit this modern take on the
Twisted Metal world or relate them to
each other a little bit more so you get
a sense that these guys cross paths
relatively often the only problem is
that they just really don't use the cars
as much as they should given what the
franchise is about
there were certain points where I was
wondering why so much of the action was
happening outside of vehicles like here
you had a perfect opportunity for
someone to get run over but then it's
just gun play or like all these
characters pulled directly from the
games in a big fight scene where they're
just punching each other and using
knives indoors I was expecting this
moment to be a setup for all the
characters to run into the parking lot
and get into their respective death
machines for a big race to steal the
prize package from John Doe but they
resolve it at the bar and we don't even
get to see these rides we also don't get
Calypso's contest yet as that's
apparently being saved for season two
it's like how that new Mortal Kombat
movie is set before the tournament
starts except this show is better than
that movie
you know by a lot it's not that I think
the show didn't want to do more of the
car battles they seem to really Revel in
it when they get the chance to do it but
it was likely a budgetary constraint
they still worked in so many nice little
touches that evoke the feeling of the
gameplay like John Doe drifting around
every corner he can getting into the
back of a semi-truck trailer for repairs
Juggernaut spawning new vehicles into
battle and running out of the bigger
weapons on your car there's even a scene
where John and quiet are customizing a
car and it feels like they're talking
about stats in the game's menu when
deciding which weapons they use it's
about balance we have weapons armor
speed and handling too much of one you
lose the other there's still a really
visible love for the source material
here especially with anything to do with
Sweet Tooth the serial killer dressed
like a clown who drives an ice cream
truck
here catch there's a good boy he's the
game series mascot because he's the most
popular character and really earns the
Twisted part of the title Samoa Joe and
Will Arnett team together to play Sweet
Tooth and it just works so well I love
that they went the Darth Vader method
where one actor plays the body and the
other is the voice both of them are just
killing it it works because they're
doing their respective job so well Samoa
Joe fills out the costume perfectly and
has such a fun screen presence he really
sells the physicality of this character
as an Unstoppable monster that's Hamming
it up and having so much fun being as
brutal as possible he moves like a
cartoon character he's just got so much
energy but Will Arnett gives a really
great performance with the voice where
he's riding the line of being funny and
genuinely unsettling
you can hide
but I have ways to find you
[Music]
damn that usually works after the first
two or three scenes I stopped even
thinking about the character being two
actors at once I just fully bought that
guy's voice was coming from behind that
guy's mask and I believed in the
performance this show is never as
exciting and fun as it is when sweet
tooth's on screen
he just totally steals the show and I
can really see the love for that
character in particular they even
brought in his paper bag best friend
from the ending of the first game in his
flaming head from the sequels plus they
revised his backstory in a way that kind
of reminded me of the movie nope so do
with that what you will
please oh I got a family
[Music]
if they're not gonna tell the truth then
I'm gonna make you shut up and bleed
plus the teasers for other major
characters has me really excited based
on how well they treated the ones here
oh and John may all your wishes come
true
you have to see more of calypso since
what little dialogue he gets feels
pulled straight from the game even the
characters in the show know he's awesome
and are excited to hear more of him wait
a minute
are you calypso
what yeah are you him
I guess that means yes John and quiet's
relationship over the course of all 10
days in the season is really well
fleshed out and they're fun to watch
together they're dysfunctional in an
entertaining way most of the time but
there are times when it does feel like
they aren't getting along just a pat out
episode length and their conflicts start
and stop repetitively it feels like
every TV show these days needs a
character development episode where the
plot stops dead in its track and the
characters are stuck in one space
arguing and planning to derail the
adventure it's that episode where the
superhero considers quitting and getting
rid of their costume maybe even loses
their powers temporarily then at the
last minute is motivated to keep going
anyway like Spider-Man no more but it
happens in the middle of every season of
Television to every character regardless
of what they're doing but even that
episode for Twisted Metal was fun in its
own way and not totally painful there's
a funny sex scene in a ball pit there
was plenty of action at the beginning
and end not so much in the Middle where
that budget was running thin love the
humor but some moments could have been
handled without spoon feeding dialogue
let the visuals speak for themselves we
also got some emotional character growth
something you would not expect only
rarely have the games did stuff like
that yeah I did get a little annoyed at
how often the main Duo argued but
surprised at where it ended up I'm
hoping peacock says hey look we don't
got anything else on our streaming
service and let's get a bunch of more
episodes and a bigger budget for this
imagine a fast and furious situation
where the first season is fairly down to
earth and yet the later Seasons may be
the clown truck mechs come in and
skeleton Racers and remote controlled
corpses you know organically work in
that fantasy stuff in there I do also
hope this show gets watched enough to
continue according to Peacock one of the
many streaming services that refuses to
make their viewer counts public this is
the most binged comedy show on their
service coming from the one place where
you can still watch the office that
should be pretty good right it's just a
shame that none of the writers and
actors who worked on it get paid any
residuals
so go support them with these resources
in the description after the
aforementioned slow spell in the Middle
episodes the season finale gives us the
car Carnage we've all been waiting for I
remember seeing the scene and turning to
my dad who was watching it with me to
say hey look the Twisted Metal is
happening and it's beautiful cars
slamming into each other missiles flying
through the air and mounted machine guns
blasting each other to scrap if I had
any complaint at all and this is likely
just the Twisted Metal black fan in me
is that I would have set this final
scene at night seeing it in broad
daylight just doesn't feel as dramatic
and shows their hand with the budgetary
limitations I can see that they just
walled off a big parking lot and local
racetrack to use for the set populated
it with a few beat up cars and I can
practically feel the edge of this set
where the real world starts again
if it were filmed at night I think it'd
be easier to obscure how small or large
this space was for the fight and it
wouldn't feel as constrained plus all
the fire and explosions would look
cooler with that orange glow in the dark
Illuminating all the busted up vehicles
our popular lips happened in 2002 I
wanted to do that because the 90s and
2000s was like when these games came out
and that's just so synonymous for me at
least with the time wait a minute why is
there a Chevy HHR there that car didn't
exist in 2002. I know because I tried
one I know it's a stupid thing to
complain about like who cuts the grass
in Walking Dead or why doesn't all the
gasoline in these cars jellify after a
certain amount of time
doesn't matter just watch Sweet Tooth
light his head on fire and have a good
time I was pleasantly surprised by the
show and I'd love to see it come back
for a season two if you're a fan of the
games or just want a decent action show
to watch check it out on peacock the
world's eighth most popular streaming
service
the actually I think ninth now special
thanks to pan the Taxi man for helping
me cover this show go check them out in
the links below I always get mad at
YouTube for not putting my videos in the
subscription box because people will
comment finally Xavier uploads again
after all these years not knowing three
other videos came out within the last
month already so maybe that stupid Bell
icon thing will help you remember I
exist if you want other ways to support
the channel you can always go hit up
that patreon for early videos and
exclusive stuff because it's just a
dollar I'm not kidding it's only one
dollar Isn't that cool if everyone who
watched this video donated one dollar a
month I'd be able to afford a house for
myself so that would be that would be
really cool you can also check out our
merch on T public or just buy some of my
random stuff on eBay I have a pretty
substantial collection of old toys that
are still in the box in perfect
condition so go take a look in case you
find something you like and lastly since
this is a YouTube video and you probably
play fortnite drop my Creator quote
Xavier GM next time you buy a silly
dancer cool character skin really helps
me out
see you next time
[Music]
foreign
thank you